Hello
bitches,
do you know,
started the salt.
No,
Dubai Sultan of Brunei rather soul,
no Bernai.
He would bring in gals and
pay them like $50,000 a month.
Just come on down and they
would go for a few months,
make quarter million bucks,
then fly home and they'd get all this
jewelry and diamonds and shit and one
little hook or ruined the whole Party.
But she was the,
they caught it with a laptop,
straightened stories about it.
She wanted to write a
book about her experience.
So this dude,
this is what he would do.
He had a disco in his house and
one of his many houses and uh,
he would have it filled with
all these girls who are making,
who knows how much money,
just tens of thousands of dollars and
he would come out and he's fucking gold
underwear and just in slippers
and slide across the room.
Like he was in that scene with Tom Cruise.
Was that movie risky
business play slides in.
He'd slide in like that as gold
underwear and just go eeny,
meeny,
miny,
moe,
and just pick one out
and just fuck shit out of them and then
the next day do the same thing and he'd
do whatever he wants and that
chick wrote the story on it.
One of them did.
Wow.
Yeah.
And there's like,
so what?
I'm going back on him.
It's really him.
That's him.
Like pack Reagan.
That guy's totally covered in gold.
Look at him.
That guy's worth more
money than you can ever.
Can I be one of these girls?
I'm like,
go away for 50,000.
I'm doing a Gig in Dubai
guys for a whole month.
You just want to be the court jester.
Go over there and crack some jokes,
man.
That's fucking crazy.
And you think he wears a condom?
No,
no condom.
Shut up.
Why would he do that?
Yeah,
exactly.
He's just shooting loads of these gals,
but then again,
he's opening himself up for possible.
I wonder if they.
I bet he gets them tested.
He puts him in catapults
and shoots him in the air.
I am closer to being Lance Armstrong,
like closest auto diets,
absent carbohydrates,
but I'm still,
you know,
now I'm just a bigger individual.
I mean,
it's interesting.
We were talking about,
uh,
you know,
I was talking to a friend of mine who
was a freshman manager of my college
football team.
So this was harvard.
Okay.
It was division two football.
It was a lot of smart
guys who couldn't make it in division one.
We had kids who went to Harvard because
they didn't get scholarships at Holy
Cross.
So they went,
okay,
I'll play football for Harvard.
They were local
19,
76.
My senior year,
the biggest kid on our team,
Danny tickets weighed 265 pounds,
six foot five tomorrow standards.
Who was enormous.
He went off to play for the Chicago
bears for five or six years.
I think we had one other
offenses Lineman who was to 65,
also six,
four,
six,
five,
maybe two this year.
Harvard football team,
smart kid,
same socioeconomic status.
The entire.
Oftentimes they get,
I think 12 players over 300 pounds.
Jesus cronies guys were enormous.
I mean,
there are six,
seven,
300 pounds.
They didn't grow people that
big when I was growing up.
I mean I could say maybe I didn't see him.
Maybe they weren't around.
Maybe they were six,
seven and they only weighed 2:30
because they weren't being bulked up.
So they were playing
basketball instead of football.
I mean I could imagine
ways that that confusing,
but from our perception,
if you look just what happened when I
was a kid in early 19 sixties as far as I
know,
there was one,
300 pounder in the NFL and afl,
two different leads back then.
Bob De remember his name,
he played for the Boston Patriots and
his head was like small compared to his
body and he was a big fat guy.
You know,
what is there now?
Twenty,
30 per team.
And you're saying like a
lot of people are saying no,
there's sciences out because they're
spending billions of dollars to do that.
The thing is,
is when you are playing such far right,
far left partisan politics,
then you have people saying,
oh,
uh,
obamacare,
he's a socialist.
He started to take over the government,
he's trying to do this,
he's trying to do that and
sort of blowing it out.
Why?
Because that creates the
tea party which you know,
comes in and then they have power and
then the tea party by the way has to go
back to their constituents and say,
we're going to repeal it,
we're going to do this,
we're going to do,
and it just becomes.
Everything goes to the atomic level
and so that when you actually go into,
into,
you know,
into Congress or into the executive
or into the Senate and you try to get
anything done,
you can't because you promised
that you're not gonna do anything.
You're not going to have
any sort of partisan.
A relation.
Bipartisan,
bipartisan.
Yeah.
It's fucked up man.
It's,
and it's stupid and it exists
because we have two parties.
When you make to people we make.
One of them were red and you
make one of them were blue.
They start wanting to fight each other.
It's a stupid theory.
So disagree.
You're also,
it doesn't matter if you're in or out,
you're always empower
because there's only two,
so you're always going to be this.
The sort of opposition.
Yeah,
and that influenced the problem is like
this is what people have to realize.
A lot of your opinions
are my opinions too.
I'm not really my opinions,
their opinions that I've decided are good
that I've heard from other people and
a lot of our patterns of behaviors from
accents to the way we approach culture,
the way we think about women,
the way we think about religion.
A lot of that is learned.
Okay.
And we have these two deeply
ingrained patterns in this country.
We have the Democrats and the Republicans
and the Republicans are these no
nonsense get business done.
You know,
and the Democrats are,
you know,
we always think of all these people are
all cry babies and they're all wishy
washy and they're bleeding hearts and and
that this is like ingrained in sort of
ingrained in our system.
These two different
patterns of behavior and they're severely
problematic because you could exhibit
a lot of traits on each sides and still
be a very good person or a lot of ideas
on each side and still
be a very good person.
Because here's the awful thing about being
an adult in a relationship or seeking
to be an adult in a relationship.
I have found when I was young and
I was a boy and I was dating girls.
It's boys and girls and she's an idiot.
You're an idiot and you do dumb things
and everyone cheats and whatever.
Then you hit a certain part of your life
where she's a woman and you're a man
and you have adult expectations and you
can't be running around being an idiot
with someone who kind of wants you to be
at the table because they are sincerely
giving time of their adult life to this
thing that you were doing together and
when you come in still thinking you're
in ninth grade and she's coming in like,
this is part of what my
life is being with you.
I have never been able to answer that in
a mature enough way to where I would've
been able to maintain it because like
say next weekend if I had a girlfriend,
she might say,
it's Friday.
What are we doing?
I'm like,
oh,
watching me write for four hours,
and so that's not the way to be.
You can't do that.
So I can't be a good persons
other half because I'm always.
The work has always attracted me
more than coming home to someone.
Wow.
Like I can't stand the idea of
someone of living with a person.
I can do it on the bus because
it's das boat and work,
you know,
going down the road.
Um,
but I,
I never would want to like
wake up and she's there
and I have no aversion.
Get expression.
They can look to your right.
She's there
every day.
Here we are together and
I'm just not wired that way.
Oh,
by the way,
did you see that?
That little clip that was making
its way around at the inauguration,
on the inauguration stand of
Bill Clinton checking you out,
getting caught.
That was Ivanka and Ivanka could've
been either one is so hard.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
God,
Jesus Christ.
Those jeans look was fantastic.
The look was pure Bill Clinton.
Oh,
well.
He was like,
fuck it.
It's over.
I don't have to hold it back anymore.
Look at it.
I'll look it up.
Oh,
good Lord.
He's shaking.
He's licking his lips.
She turns around and looks at them.
Look at that.
Oh my goodness.
And then it looks,
it gives her a quick look.
Yeah.
Well,
she turned.
Once he looks at her,
he's like,
listen bitch,
you know who I am.
You know,
you live with a wolf,
you know you live in a big old gray wolf.
She's.
Hi everyone.
I'm Ivanka trump.
Wonder,
I wish you had a fucking accent.
What's going on there?
Oh,
it's her giving them massage.
this is like a porn film that they
did a fake porn about Ivanka trump.
They that.
Look,
that quiz is beautiful girl.
That's the best part of
the inauguration day.
It's over.
I could beat me again.
I'm tired of it all.
That would be the only reason I wanted
or I would have wanted a Hillary Clinton
when the only bright spot,
I guess I should say instead,
the only bright spot to her wedding would
have been that he would have been back
in the house.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
As a first man,
man on a rampage,
he'd probably be on a rampage.
Watches watches mouth.
Yeah.
I love his mouth.
A bites.
His lower lip.
He says like Miles Ivanka?
No,
he doesn't.
Does he look.
Let me see.
Oh,
oh,
Ivanka.
Oh yeah.